governor of Lebanon Central Bank is an
international fugitive yet he remains in
office
an Interpol read notice has been issued
for Riyadh salami he is accused of
embezzling public funds and other
Financial crimes allegations he denies
the country's Judiciary is refusing to
hand him over to European Courts for
prosecution on the grounds that the
governor is already under investigation
here on similar accusations judges also
point to laws preventing the extradition
of its Nationals but few believe the
local probe will amount to anything
there's been a culture of total impunity
in Lebanon for those with power
no one has ever been of the political
class despite numerous often documented
allegations of Corruption of even in
some cases ordering uh murders and other
things no one has ever been held to
account many Lebanese have lost their
savings and the state is nearly bankrupt
after years of corruption salami who
headed the central bank for three
decades is being blamed critics say he
enabled an unsustainable system and
that's one of the reasons why he hasn't
been dismissed Lebanon the problem that
we're facing is that we have a political
class that is linked to the banking
sector and together they have made um
huge amounts of money so if he falls
there is a huge risk that the whole
political class Falls hence him being
protected by this corrupt class and by
the Judiciary the Central Bank Governor
is being investigated in at least five
European countries and says he will step
down if there is a verdict against him
but he doesn't plan to seek a new
mandate in July it is not clear how
countries where salami is implicated
will react to lebanon's decision to try
the case here but Germany's arrest
warrant issued days after France could
be an indication that International
legal pressure on salame will only
increase
so far impunity appears to have triumphs
over accountability but the net could be
closing on a man long considered
Untouchable Beirut